is it difficult for you to hear a lot of  the criticism that Eli Manning gets as a  quarterback yeah that bothers me I'm  gonna lie because it's it's not his  fault it's not the reason why we love to  put the blame on one person but it takes  11 men in a team and organization all  together to win okay what's it like  being on team with Joe Allen be  different take me to your leg work out  which one how's the quads your first  tattoo my mom was dropping me off at  school it was I was like I'm trying to  get a tattoo she was like well I'm  taking you to get your first sip of wine  September 2013 a ladies what Cummings me  by oh well you got nice ladies take it  there with Taylor rooks premieres April  3rd on the BR app